this video is sponsored by incognate
for the past year or so the term
artificial intelligence has firmly
embedded itself into our Collective
Consciousness to the point where you
cannot scroll through a news front page
without being bombarded with various
news stories about AI
students are writing essays with
artificial intelligence artists are
creating images and paintings with
artificial intelligence you can now chat
online with artificial intelligence then
there's all that weirdly awesome AI
generated Harry Potter stuff seems like
AI is suddenly everywhere could it be
that we live in the world of Terminator
and Skynet is right around the corner or
is it all just over High let's
find out a differentiation I'd like to
make at the beginning is how terminology
is used and by whom if it people want to
throw around terms like AI intelligence
or machine learning fine I have no
problem with that the problem starts
when laypeople and fluff journalists
Co-op these professional terms and blow
them up into some undiscerning
sensationalist the US Army is
now using artificial intelligence to
control drones which try to kill its own
operator oh shocking horror literally
Skynet the Terminators are coming the
machines have gained sentience also if
you're about 50 playing this game is a
must click here Grandpa don't forget
your credit card alright so first off
what is artificial intelligence well
first first off what is intelligence it
has a ton of definitions and it's a
complicated concept but for the purposes
of this video we can go with
encyclopedia britannica's definition
namely the mental quality that consists
of the abilities to learn from
experience adapt to new situations
understand and handle abstract Concepts
and use knowledge to manipulate one's
environment so can a machine do all this
no thank you for watching once again and
big thanks to incogni for sponsoring
trees hang on a minute you might say
isn't this basically what AI does it
learns from experience to generate more
and more accurate images essays and so
on it adapts and it handles abstract
Concepts like those conversation AIS as
for manipulating one's environment I'm
sure an AI could do that if you
connected one to a Boston Dynamics robot
or something so that would qualify as
artificial intelligence right and no
okay so how come it's intelligence when
you do it but not intelligence with a
machine does it let me tell you if the
rewards from returning sponsor incognate
incognate protect your privacy by
reaching out to Holders of your personal
data on your behalf and requesting its
removal these personal data ranges from
your full legal name phone number date
of birth home address or even shopping
habits the process of removal is fully
automated once launched it does not
require any further action from you
incogni will be dealing with holders of
your personal data on your behalf this
is to prevent you giving out your
contact information somewhere and then
it gets sold off so you start receiving
unwanted marketing or even scam calls or
if some website with your personal data
on it gets breached and someone takes
out a loan under your name and identity
that's not good this is where incognit
comes in or rather before all this
happens by handling personal data
removal for you on your behalf first
create an account and specify whose data
they'll be requesting to remove second
Grant incoming permission to act on your
behalf they'll be contacting holders of
your personal information to get it
wiped from their databases third kick
back and relax and watch ink only handle
all that for you you'll be able to keep
track of their progress live don't let
your personal data get into the wrong
hands the first 100 people to use my
code at the link below will get 60 off
incognate thank you for checking out
ingormate and select this help support
what I do and now back to the video
so let's take an example oh there you
are damn you're big so the cat is too
fat and needs to be put on a diet how do
we determine that we're going to compare
the older pre-ai method versus the new
AI method versus the human brain so the
older pre-ai machine I'll simplify for
brevity but basically this is what
happens when the cat is in sensor range
the machine Compares sensor data to a
data set we have various animal types
subtypes color size shape and so on the
machine selects the best fitting
categories based on the input and
outputs cat that's a great cat right
there then it Compares body shape and
size to another data set where these
specific metrics are marked overweight
put on diet the machine outputs the cat
is overweight put it on a diet and
that's the end of the process now you
might notice there is nothing
intelligent about this it's just a
mechanical comparison of data to various
lists of data with predetermined if than
outputs now let's consider how a
quote-unquote AI would handle this
instead of comparing data points to data
sets the AI statistically Associates the
shape size pattern color Etc with
domesticated Calico large rotund kits
that are overweight and need to be put
on a diet basically and how does this
work in AI Computing you don't just
write a program telling the machine to
look for a specific animal it can't like
with traditional Computing instead you
give the computer the tools with which
it is able to differentiate between
animals and correctly point out one that
is a cat at least that's the Hope in
other words in traditional Computing you
tell the computer exactly where to go to
reach a specific destination in
so-called AI Computing you give your
computer a map a booklet with basic
navigation skills and describe the
destination it should go to then
hopefully using the map and navigation
skills the computer will be able to get
to the destination on its own right so
these are basically how traditional
versus AI Computing Works in comparison
in actual intelligence yours hopefully
would handle the aforementioned get
business like so seeing the animal it
lights up specific neural connections
inside your brain leading to recognition
it's a cat pretty big too the cat's
large size shape and therefore weight
are associated with being overweight it
recognize it carries health risks which
is bad and you're empathetic towards the
cat you determine the cat should get
reduced food portions so that they'll
lose weight leave healthy year and live
longer which is a preferable outcome for
the people and animals you like because
being healthy and not dying early is a
good thing for them notice how in an
intelligent thinking process while it
seems similar to an ai's process we are
throwing around Concepts that are
incomprehensible for a machine what is
empathy why are health risks bad what is
a food portion is a concept a machine
can only answer these questions if
someone intelligent already established
these Concepts beforehand a contemporary
machine will never be able to infer any
of this on its own okay but what about
those machines that can write essays or
lead a conversation on a human level if
it acts like an intelligence talks like
an intelligence and writes like an
intelligence could it be that it is an
intelligence I would argue not really
going through the motions is one thing
actually comprehending what you're doing
is another as we'll be seeing shortly
okay but could AI potentially emerge
from this could the data sets and the
Frameworks become so large so elaborate
and so interconnected that they produce
a Consciousness somehow I do believe
they think I am some sort of God to
answer this question let's consider the
so-called Chinese room experiment
suppose we have a computer able to pass
the Turing test in Chinese meaning it
can convince a Chinese speaker that they
are speaking to a living breathing
Chinese person while in reality it's a
computer giving perfectly human passing
responses in Chinese obviously then the
experiment goes you sit down in
non-chinese speaking person in a room
with a little paper slot on the door you
give the person a book that describes
the program in English and depicts the
Chinese symbols to be outputted based on
the Chinese person's inputs but without
explaining what any of them mean
when the Chinese speaker outside slides
in a paper with texts written in Chinese
the non-chinese speaker will use the
book to draw the appropriate symbols in
response the room has enough paper
pencils erasers and cabinets for this
purpose now then the person in the room
can eventually become so adapted
following the program's written
instructions and that transcribing the
Chinese characters that the Chinese
person on the outside will think they
are talking to a real Chinese person
sitting in the room this is the
traditional pre-ai way and the same
thing happens if the person inside the
room learns what to do the same way as
an AI does so instead of a book with
instructions instructors slide in pages
with example sentences on them and the
notes describing patterns and
connections between symbols hoping the
person will eventually catch on and know
instinctively what's the like the most
accurate thing they should output in
response to a given input from the
outside whichever method you choose
whether AI or pre-ai in both cases if
the person in the room becomes Adept
enough at what they do they will pass
the Chinese Turing test however even
though they did pass the test they still
don't understand the word of Chinese
they have no idea what they're
outputting to them it's all meaningless
symbols but based on the book the pages
and the notes this is what they should
write down so they do a non-chinese
speaking person passing the Turing test
in Chinese doesn't mean they actually
understand Chinese in the same way in
computer behaving perfectly like a human
doesn't mean they are intelligent the
computer has no understanding of what
the hell it's doing it's just spewing
out a series of outputs based on various
inputs binary computers with today's
technology cannot produce intelligence
some can emulate certain aspects of it
convincingly but that's the most they
can do and this is why artificial Intel
agents isn't real I'm not saying it
can't be real but with today's computers
and Technology we are not quite there
yet so if you hear someone talk about Ai
and they don't use the terminate
professional IIT since you know it's
just empty Tech Pro hype we are
still a long way away from Ed data Hell
9000 GLaDOS Ultron and Cortana even if
people would like to pretend otherwise
thank you for watching and thanks to all
the people on my Discord in the techcom
side Channel who helped clarify the
subject for me programming and human
intelligence are complicated Affairs and
they aren't exactly my wheelhouse but I
wanted to tackle this subject anyway
because all the technical
online was really getting on my nerves
thank you for watching once again and
big thanks to incogni for sponsoring
today's video as I've said you can use
the link in the description to get 60
off and I'll be seeing you next time
[Music]